Billie lourd opens up about losing her
famous mom and grandma yeah it's
completely surreal
on Tuesday the 25 year olds got
emotional about the loss of her mom
Carrie Fisher and grandma Debbie
Reynolds during a stop by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show I mean there's no way to
really explain it it's so hard to talk
about and it's I don't know it's like if
I say that I'm doing good I'm too happy
and if I say that I'm not doing good
then I'm a mess so it's like really hard
to know what to say about it because it
is just so surreal yeah impossible to
deal with Carrie and Debbie both died
unexpectedly in December but now the
American Horror Story star says she's
glad she got a chance to appear
alongside her mom in 2015 Star Wars The
Force awakens really incredible yeah us
to get to have that experience together
the film marked Billy's first acting gig
and after Carrie saw how comfortable she
was on set she gave her daughter some
advice and I came home and my mom said
you know this is really weird that
you're comfortable here this is one of
the most uncomfortable environments in
the world like if you're comfortable
here you should do that
[Music]
you